we have a function here being defined by
an infinite series and this infinite
series if we look a little closer
inspection it's clearly a power series
each term is a is a power of x being
multiplied by some coefficient so this
for example is 2 times x to the 0 that's
just 2. and it looks like it might be a
geometric series but in order to test
that we have to make sure that there's a
common ratio that to go from one term to
the next we're multiplying by the same
by the same amount so go from 2 to
negative 8x squared what do we have to
multiply by
looking from 2 to negative 8 you have to
multiply by negative 4 and then there's
no x squared here and now there is so we
multiplied by negative 4x squared well
to go from negative 8x squared to
positive 32x to the fourth once again we
multiplied by negative 4 x squared so
each time we're multiplying by negative
4x squared we do it again right over
here so it looks pretty clear that our
common ratio is negative 4x squared now
what's neat about this is that we can
then use this information we know how to
we know how to take the sum of an of a
geometric series of an infinite
geometric series that when we know its
common ratio we've proven this in
previous videos but the formula the
formula is essentially it's the first
term right over here it's going to be 2
over
over 1 minus the common ratio well
what's the common ratio it's negative 4x
squared
negative 4x squared so if we want to
simplify this
this would be 2
over
1 plus
4
x squared so this is just neat from a
mathematical point of view we took this
infinite series this geometric series
which is a special case of a power
series and using that and using what we
know about the sums of infinite
geometric series we were able to express
this in a more traditional form now as
always you're probably thinking well you
know why was this useful
well oftentimes in mathematics you'll
actually have functions that look maybe
something like this and they're hard to
to kind of deal with in your head and
you know if you say well what as x
changes what happens to the value of the
function or is the value of the function
changes what must have happened to x but
if you can approximate this with a few
terms of the power series then this
might be an easier way to at least
approximate what's happening and this is
done in engineering and this is done in
finance and it's just interesting in
general